know you have a son ben who is i think
around two years old is that right
correct well done um what's it like
you're you're single you're in the
dating world what's it like
dating when you have a two-year-old i
did not experience that
my dating uh life you know ended and
then
i had kids and uh so i never had to
balance the two is it tricky
i actually have not dated
in a very long time just because of the
circumstances that we've been living in
but
before yes it was very weird
because people are like oh so you have a
kid
and then i'm like yeah and then i'm like
look let's look at the nanny cam
and then when they see the nanny cam
it's like it's a little bit of
a it's it's it makes it all very
real to people right but i think that's
in a way i'm going to say this i think
it's good
because you find out you find out is
this someone
if the person is freaking out about that
then you know right away
you know but if the person's like oh my
god that's amazing you know that
so it's good you're right have you ever
had an awkward thing where
um you know you're talking to someone
you're interested
and then you realize that you've got
child
you know spit up all over your face and
you realize that you've completely
compromised
no i did i was walking down the street
with
my son the other day and it was like i
was taking him to this diner around the
corner
right um for an early dinner on a sunday
and i didn't feel like bringing his
diaper bag
and i just put a diaper and some wipes
in my pocket and this diaper was like i
didn't realize but it was all coming
out of my pocket on the street and of
course it's when i'm
like checking out this super hot guy as
as you know conan when you're like
cruising a guy on the streets of new
york city you're telling me
there's a hot guy anywhere around i can
find him
i can find him legendary legendary
legendarily
well yeah thank you thank you yes
obviously
that's how you met jordan schlansky
right you produced him
that's right that's my one of our uh
producers
at the gym we have an associate producer
on the show jordan schlansky and there
he is
and um jordan schlansky is uh yes that's
how i met him
it turns out he's straight and then i
realized i'm straight
so it never developed into a
relationship oh that's too bad but
it will eventually you know obviously
i've always you guys have been ripping
on him for so long i wonder
what's holding him back from the full
producer title
uh first of all he does nothing
he does absolutely nothing and you
actually have to do something
to become a full producer he is lucky to
be an associate producer
um it's a total scam and uh
and and that's why he is not progressing
and so
yeah and i always wondered that i guess
like because i think he's in his 40s
he could be in his 50s or 60s we don't
know he is not moving forward in life
but
you know by the way very well preserved
he's very well preserved though
i wanted to pitch you on an idea i know
that you are the king of reality
television and you're a great
creator and producer of reality tv shows
what about a show with jordan
called look at that up
with the schlansky's would that interest
you at all
you know i have to say i find
you know the the poster in the marketing
is enough to get me in the tent
i have to say yeah the problem is he's a
little bit of a flatliner on the air so
i don't know what you are gonna have
it's perfect the idea is that he doesn't
even have a family
you just use digital imagery so it's not
like the kardashians where there's
actually
different distinct human beings sisters
this is
four schlansky's that are digitally
recreated and they all interact with
each other
that's the next level of reality tv you
know what
i think you're right yeah i think i want
to buy that
fta or whatever the hell it's called i
don't know what those initials mean but
it's yours
for 45 million dollars and um or
300 i don't care whatever you have on
you
i just want him gone